What's the What's the first
15?
Learn this part.
>> I don't like that.
Terrible.
I hate it.
Not only like time
It's close.
This is what this is what they're
Perfect.
Here it is.
It takes a real
What?
That would be awesome.
Hello lovely people. How are you all? I
am Jared. My pronouns are he, they. Um,
hello to my online friends as well. It's
lovely to see you. Um, I have a few
announcements as we get going tonight
and then I will help transition us into
worship with the amazing worship team
and sounds do all they do.
>> So, um, announcements. Uh our next five
low service day. So if you don't know,
we volunteer at the food pantry here
locally. Um that day is going to be on
December 6th. The kicker is you have to
sign up by tomorrow so you can get
screened or logged into the system
correctly so they can have you help. So
if you would like to help um do that,
you need to register tomorrow. You can
do that via the QR link, QR code. Um,
and we'd love to have your help with
that, especially in this uh kind of
peculiar time where not all the normal
assets might be available to people
because the government
um
so also um save the date. So since we
have a unique situation here with First
Methodist Saxi, Christmas Eve is not
available to us on the actual day. So we
will be doing Christmas Eve service on
December 21st at 5:00 p.m. So um please
uh it'll be a family-friendly service
complete with carols and a candle
lighting ceremony. Um please mark your
calendars and invite your friends and
family to join us on December 21st for
Christmas Eve service. Um, speaking of
lighting candles, we've lit some candles
here to remind us of the presence of
Jesus and the everpresent spirit. Um, as
we enter into worship. So, as we exit
the kingdom of noise, hurry, and
productivity,
now we enter the kingdom of silence,
stillness, and simplicity.
Sacred space, a place for prayer,
worship, and adoration. A place to
behold Christ. Revelation of God,
heartbeat of creation,
allow the unforced rhythms of grace to
find you, to mend your heart. May we all
come home.
>> Thanks, Jared. If you guys would stand
with us, we're going to spend some time
worshiping together. Um, I don't know
how many of you were here last week, but
we had the privilege of some of our
youth leading us in worship, and they
introduced us to this new song. Um, and
so that's going to be part of our set
tonight. And, uh, I just encourage you
guys to sing along if you know the
songs. And if you don't, um, pay
attention to the words and let those do
a work in your heart. Um, let the hope
and the encouragement from them lift you
up. and whatever you might bring be
bringing into this space tonight, it is
welcome here. So, uh this is a time for
us to bring our full selves and interact
and um worship can be something that
you're just taking in, but it also can
be an opportunity for you to um be fully
embodied and lift your hands um or open
up your posture even. The more that we
incorporate our full self into this
moment, the more that we get out of it.
So, I just encourage you guys, it's a
safe space and um try connecting in a
new way tonight as uh as you're
interacting with this spiritual
experience of of a God who loves us and
singing words about them that we believe
to be true. All right.
Where can we run?
Where can we hide?
You will not find us.
In the deepest of depths and the highest
of heights,
your love it chasees
us.
No matter where we've been,
no matter what we've done,
we can escape
your love.
Oh,
and we will never see the end. We will
never see the end
of your goodness.
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your
day.
And though we pass through the fire and
we pass through the flood,
you will be with
us.
From the dust through the valley, in the
darkest of night,
your love will be
our light.
And when we are in plenty and when we
are in want,
you will always be.
Oh,
we will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your goodness.
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your goodness.
Hey
goodness.
And in the darkest hour and on a darkest
day,
we do not have to be afraid.
For you'll never leave.
You will not forsake
the promises that you have made.
And in our darkest hour and on our
hardest day,
we do not have to be afraid.
For you'll never leave.
You will not forsake
the promises that you have made.
And we will say
that we will never see the end. We will
never see the end
of your good name.
We will never see the end. We will never
see the end
of your good. Let's sing that one more
time. And we will never see the end. We
will never see the end
of your goodness.
No, we will never see the end. We will
never see the end
of your goodness.
All right, we're going to dismiss our
kids to the kids ministry classes. You
can meet your teachers over here by
these double doors.
Hi.
Hey.
And we are going to transition into the
prayers of the people.
Um, I think most of you have been here
before, but if you haven't, up on the
screens we have
any
space
to just speak out
tonight
and that God wants to carry those
burdens with us and then we'll close out
the prayer again at the end.
Jesus for this city of Saxi, Texas and
for every city and community and all who
live in them. We pray to you for the
good earth that you have given us and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it.
We pray to you for the old and the sick,
for the widow and the orphan, for the
injured and suffering. We pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed, the
unemployed and destitute, for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them. We pray to you for the
vulnerable, the marginalized, and those
unjustly targeted for their gender,
sexuality, race, or other perceived
difference. We pray to you for those
experiencing loss, loneliness, and
disconnection. And for those struggling
with mental and emotional health, we
pray to you, Lord. We know that you love
us and that you hear us. So, we lift
these names and situations up to you.
trust you.
Amen.
For the names and the moments that we
have spoken aloud and for those that we
have kept in our hearts, we pray to you
that they may have life and light,
healing and hope, peace and a deep sense
of your presence. Amen.
It doesn't matter if the whole world
turns
away. I will be with you.
I will stay with you.
It doesn't matter if the whole world
turns
away. I will stay with you, my God.
I will stay with you. Let's sing that
again. It doesn't matter if the whole
world turns
away. I will stay with you, my God.
I will stay with you.
It doesn't matter if the whole world
turns
away. I will stay with you, my God.
I will stay with you.
For where can I go? Where can I go?
Where can I go?
If only you have the words of life. Only
you have the words of life. Where can I
go? Where can I go? Where can I go?
When only you have the words of life?
Only you have the word.
It doesn't matter if the whole world
turns
away. I will stay with you, my God.
I will stay with you.
It doesn't matter if the whole world
turns
away.
I will stay with you, my God.
I will stay with you.
For where can I go? Where can I go?
Where can I go?
When only you have the words of life.
Only you have the words of life. Where
can I go? Where can I go? Where can I
go?
When only you have the words of life.
Only you have the words of life.
on the earth.
No other world's going to satisfy.
No other words going to be my life. No
other love that I'm turning to. Jesus,
you're my breakthrough.
No other wealth's going to sisfy.
No other word's going to be my life. No
other love that I'm turning to. Jesus,
you're my Let's sing that one more time.
No other world's going to sisfy.
No other world's going to be my light.
No other love that I'm turning to.
Jesus, you're my breakthrough.
Jesus, you're my faith.
Jesus will not break through.
It doesn't matter if the whole world
turns
away. I will stay with you, my God.
I will stay with you.
It doesn't matter if the whole world
turns
away.
I will stay with you, my God.
I will stay with you.
Cuz where can I go? Where can I go?
Where can I go?
When only you have the words of life?
Only you have the words of life. Where
can I go? Where can I go? Where can I
go?
With only you have the words of life.
Only you have the words of life. Only
you have the words of life. Only you
have the words of life. Only you have
the words of life.
Only you have the words of life.
This week was um one of our not not
easiest weeks in my family. We had a lot
of sickness going through the household,
some disappointments. It was just kind
of one thing after another it felt like
um and one of the things that I hang on
to in in those moments where you just
feel exhausted, you're sleepd deprived,
you know, um it's just some of some of
the things that I remember from the
Bible like his mercies are new every
morning. Some of those words that just
sustain you, you know, I'm the bread of
life. those little phrases from his word
that just where else can I go when when
I'm at the end of my rope and I'm broken
down, I'm tired, I'm discouraged,
it's just his word that sometimes gets
me through that next moment. Or even
just his mercy, knowing that I fail, but
then I can get back up. You know, like
I'm the author and the perfector of your
faith.
the good shepherd knowing that he's with
us, that he goes before us, that he's
behind us, he's our rear guard.
And it's it's in those moments when you
feel like you have nothing left to give
that sometimes for me, I feel like he
becomes enough.
He is sustaining us. He is pulling us
forward.
And you can find some gratitude in that
even whenever everything seems to be
going wrong.
There is this kind of broken hallelujah
that can ring out when you make it to
the end. When you lay your head down for
the night, even if it's a sleepless
night, and you just know there's going
to be a new day, a new dawn, and he's
still going to be there.
God, our father, our mother, she's still
going to be pulling us forward, covering
us in her wings, sheltering us in the
storm.
This song is called gratitude and
Jesse's going to lead it. Um, so
tonight, whatever you might be facing, I
just encourage you
to try to find just even if it's
something small, something that you're
grateful for and just hang on to that.
Let it be an anchor of hope in your
storm tonight.
All my words fall short
and I've got nothing new.
How could I express
all my gratitude?
And I could sing these songs
as I ofen,
but every song will stand
and you never do.
So I throw up my hands and praise you
again and again.
Cuz all that I have is a hallelujah.
And I know it's not much, but I'm
nothing else fit for a king
except for a heart singing hallelujah.
Hallelujah.
I've got one response.
I've got just one
with my arms stretched wide.
I will worship you, Lord.
So I throw up my hands and praise you
again and again.
Cuz all that I have is a hallelujah.
And I know it's not much, but I'm
nothing else fit for a king
except for a heart singing hallelujah.
Hallelujah.
Come on my soul. Oh, don't you get shy
of me. Lift up your soul cuz you've got
a lion inside of those lungs. Give up
and praise the Lord.
Oh come on my soul. Oh don't you shine
me. Lift up your soul.
You got light inside of us.
Get up and praise the Lord.
on my soul. Oh, don't you give shiny
gift of your soul.
You got light inside of us.
Get up and praise the Lord.
Heat.
So I throw up my hands,
praise you again and again.
Cuz all that I have is a heart.
Hallelujah.
And I know it's not much, but I've
nothing else fit for a king
except for a heart singing hallelujah.
Hallelujah.
God, thank you that you are good,
that you are for us and not against us.
that you pull us out of our muk and our
meer and you set our feet on a rock.
Thank you that you gather your children
from all four corners of the earth
and you pull us together under your
wing.
You shelter us.
You comfort us.
God, tonight we're grateful for that
kind of love.
Would that gratitude carry us through
this next week,
through every hard moment, every dark
day?
God, would your light guide us?
Would it rise up within us like a song?
Would it lift our heads?
God, would we remember to go to your
word? And would it be a lamp unto our
feet and a light unto our path?
Because only you have the words of life.
God, help us to remember to turn to you.
our everpresent help in times of
trouble.
We love you, God, and we invite you into
this space with us tonight.
Would you speak to our hearts?
Would you remind us who's we are?
It's in your name I pray. Amen.
Thank you guys for singing with us. If
y'all would turn to the person on your
right and left and say, "The peace of
Christ be with you."
Well, grace and peace. It is so good to
be with you all. My name is Brett.
Pronouns he, him, and uh yeah, it's a
joy, a joy to welcome you into this
space as always. That includes those
joining us online. Love you all lots.
And anyone here tonight who is new, if
this is your first time or just your
first time, you know, in a long time. Um
we're really really glad that you're
you're here with us among us. Um so
let's see. The title of my message this
week is when everything is shaken. And
uh if you've been a part of the table
for a while, you know we tend to do
different types of series. Sometimes
we'll go through like a book of the
Bible. Sometimes we'll do something more
topical like our last two series have
been kind of more on like a topic. And
other times we will just jump into uh
what's known as the church calendar
basically. Um kind of joining in. I
think it's important to kind of join in
with a larger church in certain times
and seasons. Uh so we tend to follow the
United Methodists even though
technically we're not United Methodists
though we you might be fooled since we
meet you in a building but um but I I do
love their liturgy and uh their kind of
lectionary readings. So there's kind of
you know certain scriptures that are
prescribed for various times. So the
next two weeks will be kind of some
one-off messages and we're going to be
following the lectionary in those. And
uh part of the reason I love that is not
only the sense of joining in with the
broader church, but uh also it kind of
will kind of nudge me into different
areas, topics, you know, like you never
know what's coming out of like the
reading. Like I just I'm as like, you
know, kind of uh intrigued as you like
when I just kind of pull it up like,
"All right, well, let's see what the
passages are this week, you know, and
just like the Old Testament readings and
the Psalm and the Gospel reading and
then the Epistle and from the New
Testament." And so I just, you know,
choose from one of those. Um but it's uh
it never ceases. I don't know. There's
always something um beautiful and
insightful in these these texts. So um
it's also a good time to jump on the
church calendar because we're coming
into the season of like advent and then
like Christmas tide and then Lent and
you Easter and all that that whole
season. So we tend to to kind of be more
in the church calendar in this next you
know coming five six months or so. Um so
with that in mind our gospel reading
this week is from Luke chapter 21 uh
verses 5-6. So quite a short uh little
little text. It says this. Some of his
disciples were remarking about how the
temple was adorned with beautiful stones
and with gifts dedicated to God. But
Jesus said, "As for what you see here,
the time will come when not one stone
will be left on another.
Every one of them will be thrown down."
So this passage it may strike us as I
don't know one of the more kind of
strange or kind of cryptic you know
sayings of Jesus and we might wonder
like I don't know how does this have
anything to do with you know our own
lives and our own kind of moment uh but
I think there's a lot more than meets
the eye going on here. So to kind of
understand what's going on in this short
little narrative u we need to first
understand some background and some
history. So basically it's a it's a
history about the temple and how
absolutely
central and essential um it was to the
the Jewish people of Judaism of uh
Christ's time and era. So um the the
temple we have some images here. So the
this first one is um the temple was
completed for the first time in 957
um BCE uh under King Solomon. So it was
like the absolute crown jewel of not
only Jewish like religion at that time
but really you know political life,
social life, cultural life. I mean it
was just the the center of everything,
the center of Jerusalem and the center
of of their really their whole
existence. Uh, and that's why it was so
absolutely crushing when it was
destroyed 370 years later by the
conquering Babylonian Empire uh in 587
B.CE. If you want to get like a little
bit of a feel for just what a absolute
catastrophe that was in the hearts and
minds of uh God's people living at that
time, you can go read the book of
Lamentations in the Bible. It was
written right after the destruction of
the temple. You can hear the word lament
in that title lamentations, right? And
it it is a a book of lament. Um though
also interesting that kind of
acknowledgement of the goodness of God.
Actually the quote one of the scriptures
Mindy quoted um about the steadfast love
of the Lord never ceasing his mercies
never come to an end. They're new every
morning. Great is thy faithfulness Lord.
That's actually like from Lamentations
3. But but but that's you know that's
few and far between the book of
Lamentations. Mostly it is like oh my
gosh God where are you? Right? This just
was an absolute national catastrophe
and the ruins of the temple stood for
nearly 50 years. The way the Babylonians
kind of went about this whenever they
conquered a people, they basically took
like all of the kind of educated like
elites and the business leaders and the
the priests and I mean just sort of
everyone who was sort of at least in the
kind of running the society so to speak.
everyone and they they would take them
all off back to Babylon to kind of
bolster the empire um and they would
leave maybe a few thousand um peasants
and folks there in Jerusalem. So there
were some Jewish people that remained
there but you know by and large it was
mostly the people were exiled. So that's
why the temple just stood it was just in
ruins or they didn't have the people
power to like do anything. So it stood
um in ruins for 50 years until miracle
of miracles um Cyrus the great uh who
was uh king of Persia at the time. There
was kind of just empire after empire. If
you read the Bible, it's really in a way
a history of the ancient near east and
it's just the story of the Assyrians and
the Babylonians and then the Mes and
then the Persians and and eventually
we'll get to the Romans, right? It's
just empire after empire conquering
conquering conquering. So, uh, once the
Persians came to power, they actually,
Miracle of Miracles, they let some of
the Jewish people, um, a huge contingent
of them return home.
And what do you think was the first
thing they set about doing,
rebuilding that temple, uh, which they
were, I mean, the work basically began
immediately. It was completed, um, 22
years later, 517 B.CE. So from kind of
that first destruction at the end it was
like 70 years that it kind of stood
there um and was finally rebuilt. By
some accounts this is known as the
second temple. Um not quite as glorious
as the first one partly be just just
because you know culturally like they
didn't like Solomon and that first
building the temple that was like the
peak of their wealth and power and you
know so they could just put so much into
that temple. The second one right you
can see because the history they didn't
quite have the same resources. Um,
nonetheless though, it was a remarkable
structure like especially for its time,
you know, I mean, just absolutely
beautiful. Um, incredible. And, uh,
again, it served as the very heart of
of, uh, Judaism and and the Jewish faith
and life there. Just everything to the
people. And there that second temple
stood for over 500 years. Just think of
that scope of time. you know like even
here in the US you know we don't haven't
even been around for h barely half that
you know what I mean um so 500 years it
had stood by the time we reached the
days when Christ and his disciples
walked those dusty streets and this is
why the disciples turn to Jesus and say
just look at it isn't it beautiful isn't
it stunning and look at the people's
devotion
like look how they bring their their
gifts dedicated to God here. What a
perfect place. Truly the Lord is with
us. And how do we know kind of by
implication what they're saying? You
know the kind of text underneath the
text is because of this remarkable
building, this holy place, right? You
can see how it was this just central
powerful
symbol. And I don't know how the word
symbol that resonates with you, but like
symbols to human beings are everything,
you know? I mean, this is why someone
like burns an American flag. You're
like, "Oh, it's just a piece of cloth."
It's it's a symbol, right? It it
symbolizes
sort of the nation, the you know what I
mean to to where which is why that the
destruction of the temple. It wasn't
just like, "Oh man, our favorite
building got knocked out." Like, no, no,
it was everything, right? Uh, and so now
this is why it resonates with them. It's
this powerful symbol effect in a lot of
ways like here in the US, you know, we
have kind of our own of course symbols
deeply meaningful to us, but I don't
know if anything has quite the the
symbolic power. It would almost be like
religiously like if you were Mormon and
you had like the the Mormon the temple
there in Salt Lake City kind of like
combine that with like the Lincoln
Memorial, combine that with like the 911
memorial in New York, you know? It's
like and just combine the kind of
religious, political, social symbolism
all into one and like that's the meaning
and the passion they had for uh this
this symbol. It it really it came for
them it really came to be a source of um
of deep profound kind of pride. Um not
just in a negative sense though you
could argue kind of over time um that
did kind of set in. Um but it was almost
I think the the challenge with it almost
became a kind of extension of their um
kind of identity
right in the same way our symbols right
we this happens to us too right we human
beings we love our symbols and they
become a kind of extension of us
and it's almost like the mindset was
we're great because that's great
so
this is why Jesus receive response
though is so absolutely like surprising
in that basically he doesn't he doesn't
say kind of par it back to them yes it
really is remarkable you know I'm
confident I'm confident it will stand
for generations to come
no what is did you catch it in the story
what does he say he's like a day will
come when not one stone will be left
upon another sure enough about 40 years
after that moment
during the Jewish Roman war the Romans
demolished the second temple in
Jerusalem it has not been rebuilt to
this very day.
So what what does this mean you know for
us for our own kind of day our own time?
I might want to kind of get us thinking
in in this way by naming that humans
like in essence we're not so different
from them. Humans were always looking
for refuge
a kind of bull work against the chaos a
safe harbor from the storm we call life.
I think architecture often reflects
this. You know, there's a reason that we
want our political, religious, and
cultural institutions to look
unshakable.
We have a a few examples of this um as
well. If we could put up those those
images, right? Churches, banks, the New
York Stock Exchange, the National
Archives in Washington DC, right? It's
it's very much on purpose that things
these things are not built in like in a
frail little building like a strip mall,
right? No, no, no, no. That why? Because
the architecture itself speaks, right?
What's that architecture? What is it?
What is it saying to you as you look at
that? It's in essence, it's
communicating, hey, we aren't going
anywhere. Look at these pillars. Look at
this stone. You You think You think
these are falling down tomorrow?
You think you can destroy this? Oh, just
try. You cannot. No one can. Why? What's
it communicating? It's saying because
we're timeless. Because we're
trustworthy. Because we're unshakable.
And we will be here. We will be here for
you and your kids and your grandkids and
generations to come. You can count on
us.
You say, "You see all that in those
stones?" I do. That's what I That's what
I I do think like this is where
architecture weirdly influences us, you
know, in ways we're not even like
consciously aware of. But it it speaks.
Now, of course, it's way beyond
architecture alone, right? It's all
sorts of cultural kind of rhythms and
liturgies. We see it in the solemn oaths
that we take at various points in our
lives. you know, we if you join the
armed forces,
uh it's not just some kind of like,
yeah, I think I'll give this a whirl,
you know, like no, there's you swear to
something, right? You commit yourself to
something. It's similar um with
marriage, of course, right? Till death
do us part and such. We see it in
religion, too, right? the various
symbols and theologies and uh things
people kind of like one person for
example in our story they hang their hat
on the temple in Jerusalem another in
the Catholic hierarchy right Protestant
kind of Christians in the Bible as a
kind of perfect document at least some
uh Protestants uh Muslims in the Quran
as a flawless text
we see it very much in the political
world right now in other words this
isn't just a religious thing. Uh people
I think can sense the ties that bind us
fraying. I don't often get pulled into
Facebook kind of comments and such, but
occasionally I feel prompted to speak
out and some of you may have seen a few
weeks ago I felt kind of prompted to
chime in on uh some of where I see this
playing out in the culture and I what I
think are kind of dangerous ways. Um,
but some what I was trying to speak to
there was there's a kind of anxiety in
the nation and there's a there's a lot
of political polarization
and a lot of change and so people react
right and there's a kind of almost an
overreaction where we say well look God
is for us and our nation state will
endure.
Uh for example, there was a recent
political and religious gathering where
I was struck by what one of the speakers
there said. They said, "Western
civilization will endure."
And then they said, "And we," and they
inserted the name of their political
organization. They said, "And we will
last forever."
I think that's quite a statement,
right? But but this is what humans human
beings do, right? We we need or at least
we feel we need these these kinds of
symbols and structures and kind of roots
to kind of ground ourselves,
right?
And in so many ways that phrase, it
sounds just like the disciples in Luke
21.
Look at what we've built.
Look at it. It's so beautiful. It's so
powerful.
To which Jesus responds,
you see, humans were always looking for
that refuge, that bull work against the
chaos. I think this is where the
Christian saints and mystics are.
They're helpful,
but they're also gadflies.
you know, they're they're helpful
because they see further than we do.
And and they basically kind of warn us.
They're like, "Careful,
don't do it. Don't put your ultimate
hope in these things.
Put your hope in God, the source, the
foundation, the ground of all things,
the only one who does not change.
And so at times, right, they kind of
like Jesus um they sound kind of harsh
like they sound they're just like
they're cold comfort to us just like the
disciples. They wanted a better response
than actually no not one stone will be
left upon you. This is not what they
were looking for, you know. Uh but it
was the message they needed.
It was good medicine because Christ is
naming that these institutions and
systems that we build the these
institutions and buildings and
traditions whether religious or
political or you know all of all the
cultural things that we do as human
beings that that those things say
everything's fine. We have everything
under control. You can trust us. We'll
be here forever.
And Christ is just warning us, naming
like, huh, here's the truth. These
things are human. Oh, so human. They are
beautiful
and flawed. They are good and bad. They
are fragile. Oh, so fragile. More
fragile than anyone would ever care to
admit. certainly more fragile than that
architecture
would try and communicate.
Now, I I do think there's there's kind
of political implications, you know, for
Christians to what Jesus is naming here.
You know, I I do I think Christians can
and should participate in civic life, in
political life. I think that's um that's
good. Um, and at the same time, in light
of Jesus kind of words here, I think at
the same time, we can't become too
enthralled
by it, right? In essence, should not put
all our hope in it. And that's some of
what I'm kind of seeing in the broader
culture right now where there's a lot of
from that place of anxiety. There's a
lot of um kind of emphasis being placed
on these humano institutions and such as
A KIND OF BULL WORK that we can trust
and rely on forever. And it's like
you're going to be so disappointed. Um
this is only the language we should
reserve for God and God alone. So I do
think there's kind of social political
implications here. Um, but where I want
to actually take this is somewhere a
little bit more personal because
sometimes we can keep that critique a
little bit out there outside the walls
like oh yeah those people they really
have that problem you know but good
thing we don't. Um and I I think I want
to turn this a little more towards
myself um and us to say like well what
what can we really glean from this and
what I would want to name is I think in
a way um these kind of we might call
institutional egos which is kind of
interesting to think of like communities
having a kind of collective ego. I found
this idea very helpful. Um I think in a
way institutional egos are a kind of
mirror. They're like a reflection of the
personal egos that make them up. In
other words, in the same way a church or
a bank or a nation state is kind of
constantly trying to communicate, you
know, this sense of like don't worry,
everything's fine. We got this. Uh we're
in control. It's great. It's great. It's
great. We're good. We're good. you know,
um I think human beings as individuals,
we do this too. Uh I mean, I do this
too, right? And and this is what
scripture though refers to um as kind of
the false self or we might call it the
egoic self. basically this this kind of
weird uh part of us that tends to use
people and positions and titles to kind
of try and like construct this narrative
this story about ourself and of course
the narrative kind of differs for all of
us you know but there's like we're not
like that creative you know what I mean
like in the end uh there's similar
themes you know it's something like I am
this is again it's about identity so I'm
worthy
I'm valuable
because
now this is where we tend to go wrong,
right? Because it is true that you are
valuable and worthy and loved because
God loves you. Because God sees you,
because God sustains you, right? That's
the truth. But this is where we take it
is no, no, I I'm worthy. I'm valuable.
I'm loved because and it's something
outside my because my kids are so good.
You say, I've seen your kid. Most of the
time my voice can get a little crazy but
my kids are so good you know um because
uh because of how productive I am or
this one we love like the material
possessions because of just you know
just look at my car look at my clothes
or look at what neighborhood I live in
or look at where I work you wouldn't
believe the degrees you know what we
just have these things we're constantly
telling the story about you know uh
grounding ourself and identity. The way
um Thomas Merin put it uh is this. He
said, "All sin starts from the
assumption that my false self, the self
that exists only in my own egocentric
desires, is the fundamental reality of
life to which everything else in the
universe is ordered."
It's a that's a profound quote. In
essence, right, we start to kind of
think like we it's almost like we tell
this story that's like sort of a
fiction, but then we believe it and then
we like live our whole life from as
though the whole world centers around
that truth only the problem is not even
true. You you know this is where we get
all weird. Uh and again we can do this
sort of socio kind of sociopolitically
you know or we do it individually.
I'm great where you know because of all
these this this story.
Now there is good news though initially
I admit it may sound like bad news which
is why folks like Jesus and a lot of the
teachers and saints and mystics down
through the centuries often sound to us
kind of like negative you know but it's
it's actually because they're trying to
set us free right from these shackles
that b so it sounds like oh you're a
downer but he says no they're a downer
on the fakeness on the falseness on what
is not true you know what I mean so it's
it's actually quite good but it sounds
bad so here's kind of how I might frame
the good news at some point.
By the way, even if it's at death,
because I think death is like the
ultimate letting go moment, at some
point my false self is shaken and
collapses until not one stone is left
upon another.
It might be from illness. Some of you
have have been through this, are in the
midst of it right now.
uh illness, job loss, marital breakdown,
adult children now out of your control,
workcoholism, some other ism, addiction,
right? It it may even simply be from a
kind of a feeling of failure, you know,
of like you've told yourself this story,
then you haven't even been able to live
up to like the story. U that's the one I
personally resonate with with um this
kind of has been continues to be how my
own false self like rears its ugly head.
I've told this in some various sermons,
so I won't go into like all the details
again, but basically I just I tend to be
someone with like these sort of high
standards for myself and with a certain
insecurity
in my at times failure to reach them and
live into them. And like the way this
plays out is I'm always looking for like
some future moment
when I will arrive.
Anyone there waiting for the day when
you will arrive?
You know, like this time when my egoic
project shall be complete. A time when
I'll finally have the admiration of
everyone around me. It's completely
ridiculous, you know, but I this is what
I long for, you know. And then I'll know
then I'll know I'm enough.
I'm enough.
Ah, but thanks be to God. He has
thwarted every plan of mine.
And slowly but surely, it's a process,
you know. I'm I'm dying to that as I
realize, ah crap, it's my false self.
It's this fake egoic weird little
insecure story I'm like trying to
convince everyone else and myself of,
you know, it's ridiculous.
I'm just trying to plant my flag
somewhere.
I had a I met with a friend a few weeks
ago and uh great guy, one of the just
smartest people I know. Um very
successful. He's founded like multiple
like tech companies and just kind of one
of those people that like is like easy
to be jealous of like kind of has it
all, you know, just has wonderful like
wife and family and job and money and
you know all this stuff. And so we got
coffee and uh of course you know to kind
of open up he's like hey how how are
you? How you been? It had been quite a
while since we got together and I've
learned in these moments partly it's
through this journey of like trying to
not be so fake and you know tell this oh
great great man great oh yeah you know
um learning to be like honest you know
so I said you know I mean overall I'm
I'm blessed I have a good life um but I
won't lie the last two years it's been
real challenging
and I said I think I think at this point
in my life you know kind of old middle
age is catching up to me I just I
expected I'm here I expected to be there
somewhere down there, you know, instead
I'm here and it's been so like hard and
at times a little even humiliating and
it's so challenging, you know, and it
was like in me kind of opening up it
seemed like it kind of I don't know I
gave him permission you know what I mean
how this will happen when you're a
little bit vulnerable than often other
people far from judging we often fear
they're gonna judge me and they're going
to be like oh my gosh yeah yeah why are
you such a failure you know but no of
course people are like oh well me too
you know what I mean and it was like it
opened up a little space and He started
to share and he said um you know about a
year and a half ago I opened up to my
wife in like some very deep ways and I
had to tell her I am not who you think I
am. He said I confessed things to her
that night that I swore I would take to
my grave.
He said but you know what that moment a
year and a half ago that has set me
free.
And I heard him speaking and I thought,
my goodness, that's it.
Not one stone left upon another.
That's the shaking.
That's the That's the crumbling.
We might put it like this. We could say
immature religion uses God
to inflate our institutional and
personal egos. Hey, hey, look at us.
Look, look at our institution. Look at
our church. Look at our temple. Look at
our country, our tribe. And of course,
you know, kind of a side effect. Hey,
look at me. You know, you wouldn't
believe how successful or whatever.
By grace, of course. All by grace.
Mature religion pops our false self like
a balloon. We become empty, empty,
empty.
But in that letting go, we fall into the
very arms of God and begin to receive
our identity as in our life as a gift.
We might say rather than trying to kind
of establish our sense of self through
our own kind of either social
nationalistic or religious, you know,
kind of striving um or even just our own
individual striving. We begin to receive
we receive
our life as a gift of God. Our identity
and rootedness as a gift of God. In
essence, the true temple
in other words your true identity never
consists of anything anyone can see
which is what our ego would love. You
know, titles and positions and roles
etc. It is and always has been and
always will be hidden with Christ in
God.
So, kind of in closing, how can we step
into this here? Um, one of our core
values at the table is vulnerability.
And so, here's the practice. I want to
invite you to engage at some point like
in the next, you know, week or two. Find
someone or a group of someone's who you
feel you can trust and share one level
deeper than you normally would.
Your egoic false self will hate this. it
will say this is very dangerous is a
huge problem you know like you're
humiliating yourself you know etc etc
the more crazy your mind's going the
more you know oh it's working you know
like this is a good this is a good path
um
and but what happens as you do this
you're you're learning to kind of
operate in that true self like look this
is just who I actually really am
in that kind of simplicity
you know maybe you've been attending a
meetup for months or years, but you kind
of keep those cards close to the chest.
You know what I mean? Or maybe you have
a spiritual director or a therapist or a
friend you like you share with, you
know, but you always kind of hold back.
There's levels, there's places you're
not willing to go. Man, I encourage you,
find someone you can trust and step into
that place of a of a willed
vulnerability, a kind of uh an a
transparency, an honesty.
When you do that, it will feel like a
shaking. I promise you, those stones
will tremble. But it's in that crumbling
that the false self begins to fall away.
And the true self is allowed to shine
forth, the Christlike self in each and
every one of us. In the name of the
Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
Amen.
So on the night Jesus was betrayed, he
had one final meal with his disciples.
And at that meal, he held up a loaf of
bread and he broke it and he said, "Take
it. Eat. This is my body. It's broken
for you." And he held up a cup of wine.
He said, "Take this drink. This is my
blood. It's shed for you. Whenever you
eat this bread, whenever you drink this
cup, remember me." And so, as we come
forward, we're participating in that
mystery. We're remembering. We're
connecting with the crucified and risen
one. uh the one who accepts us just as
we are. So the way we'll participate in
communion tonight is we'll just start
here at the front. We'll go row by row
uh forming one line here in the middle.
So when one row is done, the next one
can go ahead and get in line. Um we
practice what's called an open table.
Meaning if you're here tonight and you'd
like to participate, then you are free
to do that regardless of your, you know,
exact like theology or denomination or
whatever. If something in you wants to
connect with Jesus, then you're you feel
free to um come forward. At the same
time, there's no pressure. If you'd
rather not, that's okay, too. You should
know the red is wine, the white is grape
juice. And finally, you can just partake
whenever and however you'd like. Some
folks like to come and kneel here at the
front. Um, others like to partake
immediately. Some return to their seats
for kind of a moment, and then they
take, but no one will lead you through
the exact moment of taking. So, this is
the table, not of the church, but of the
Lord. And it's made ready for those who
love him and for those who want to love
him more. So come you who have much
faith and you who have little. You who
have been here often and you who have
not been here long. You who have tried
to follow and you who feel like you've
failed. Come. Come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you and it's
his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here. Come to the table.
We're going to close with a song tonight
called Known and Loved. And we haven't
done it for quite a while. Um, so you're
welcome to just sit back and reflect on
this song um if you would like. But the
words of the chorus are very simple and
straightforward. It just says, "We are
known and loved." known and loved by
you. And I just think about that story
that Brett was just telling us about
that guy who opened up about things that
he had never shared before. And um
something that is a comfort to me is
knowing that there isn't something in my
life that God is not already aware of.
There's there is no hiding. There's
there's no use in hiding from the one
who created me, from the one who made
me. Um there is only love there for me.
So, I hope we hold on to that this week
um as we um as we dare to be vulnerable
like Brett was saying and and uh share
our true self with with the people that
we're closest with. Um so, Jesse's going
to lead us in this song and you guys are
welcome to sit back or stand and sing
either one, but let's focus on those
words.
We've been hiding
in the shadows,
lost and afraid of you.
We've been wondering
in the darkness.
But if we only knew,
we are known and loved.
Known and loved. We are known and loved
by you.
You've been waiting
to show us mercy.
Your presence is our own.
>> We're your children.
Love forever
now. Every fear is gone.
We are known in love.
Known in love. We are known in love by
you. We are known. We are known in love.
Known in love. We are no
good by you.
There is no fear anymore.
All of his mercy.
There is no fear in your love.
There is no fear
anymore
cuz you're the God of mercy.
There is no fear
in your love
cuz you're
mercy.
There is no fear
anymore.
Cuz all that's left is mercy.
There is no fear
in your love.
In your love.
We are known in love.
Known in love. We are known in love by
you.
Thank you so much for joining us
tonight. Um, if you were a visitor, um,
we would love if you would, uh, take a
moment to fill out a visitor card on the
small table over there, or you can fill
it out with the QR code online if you
haven't done so already. Um, that just
lets us know you were here, and we like
that. Um,
also of note, um, Meetup groups, Brett
kind of mentioned them in the service,
but Meetup groups, uh, are listed online
at the QR code, but it's a great way to
connect with people. You might see here,
um, on a little deeper level. Um, I did
one on a Sunday morning. We're in a book
club. I just dropped my phone,
which I'm going to need in just a
second. So, um,
yeah, sorry. meetup groups. Um they're a
great thing. I highly encourage you to
uh get involved in one. Um and finally,
let me send you into this week of the
men addiction.
If you can put yourself into a posture
to receive or just open your heart to
these words,
you are a child of God.
You are a child of God. This is true on
your best day. And it's true on your
worst day. So as you go into your week
ahead with it yet to be determined highs
and lows and everything in between,
go filled with the assurance that you
are loved.
You are worthy
and you are accepted just as you are.
and go filled with God's Holy Spirit and
a desire to extend those same gifts of
grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with. Be blessed and
we'll see you next Sunday.
We are known in love.
known in love. We are known in love by
you.
>> We are known in love.
>> Known in love. We are known in love by
you.
>> We are known in love by you.
You did that.
>> That was one of my favorite.